yield farming it sounds like something
you do in world of warcraft but the year
is 2022 and the world has changed magic
internet money is here ladies and
gentlemen and yield farming it's a
crypto thing now so buckle up educate
yourselves this is what it really means
hang on let me look this up real quick
ah yes yield farming is the practice of
staking or lending crypto assets in
order to generate high returns or
rewards in the form of additional
cryptocurrency now are you confused yet
don't be because that's the whole
purpose of this video sam bankman freed
ceo one of the world's largest crypto
exchanges is here he appeared on a
podcast to explain it to the unwashed
masses once and for all what is a yield
farm but it turns out in the process he
accidentally describes a ponzi scheme
which is just sort of like really funny
because his one job in situations like
this talking to non-crypto people is to
reassure them this isn't a ponzi scheme
guys and instead just right out of the
gate off rip he's like yeah we just kind
of keep putting money into this thing
and it just price goes up now as a
disclaimer not all yield farming is a
ponzi scheme people have been lending
money forever and that's technically
yield farming that's not a ponzi scheme
now on the other hand the point of this
video is that what this billionaire
crypto ceo is about to describe that is
definitely a ponzi scheme so uh
let's just check it out a surprising
amount of legitimacy for what farming
could mean you know where'd you start
you start with
a company that builds a box
and in practice this box they probably
dress it up to look like a
life-changing you know world-altering
protocol that's gonna replace all the
big banks in 38 days or whatever maybe
for now actually ignore what it does or
pretend it does literally nothing it's
just a boss all right step one
we're already getting some red flags
here pretend you're life-changing and
actually do nothing okay
what's step two sam and then this
protocol issues a token we'll call it
whatever x token
and x token promises that anything cool
that happens because of this box
is gonna
ultimately be usable by
you know governance vote of holders of
the x tokens they can vote on what to do
with any proceeds or other cool things
that happen from this box and of course
so far we haven't exactly given a
compelling reason for why there ever
would be any proceeds from this box
but i don't know you know maybe there
will be so that's sort of where you
start and now what happens well
x token has some market cap right it's
probably not zero well let's say it's
you know 20 million dollar market cap
okay step two make a 20 million dollar
market cap from nothing no big deal guys
it's crypto now
the interviewer this guy matt levine
sort of picks up on the insanity of this
he's like this serious investment banker
guy you have to imagine and he's like
look no it can't be worth nothing you
you can't do this and sam bankman
freed's like the hell i can't from like
first principles it should be zero but
okay
uh sure okay i i
completely reasonable comment
like i mean like that's not quite true
but it's like when you describe it in
this totally cynical way it sounds like
it should be here but go describe it
this way you might think for instance
that in like five minutes with an
internet connection you could create
such a box and such a token and that it
should reflect like
you know it should be worth like a
hundred eighty dollars or something
market cap for like that you know that
effort that you put into it in the world
that we're in if you do this everyone's
gonna be like oh box token maybe it's
cool if you buy any box token you know
that's gonna appear on twitter and i'll
have a 20 million dollar market cap all
right red flag 3. my man just said maybe
in your world a box that does nothing
can't be worth 20 million but in my
world 20 million minimum and this is
sort of where things go full ponzi full
we don't even try to hide it money goes
up because more money goes in and more
money is going in because money goes
up
so
you know x tokens being given out each
day all these like sophisticated firms
like huh that's interesting like if the
total amount of money in the box is 100
million dollars
then it's gonna yield 16 million dollars
this year
in x tokens being given out for it
that's a 16 return that's pretty good
we'll put a little bit more in right
and and maybe that that happens until
there are 200 million dollars in the box
so you know sophisticated traders and or
people on crypto twitter or or other
sort of similar parties go and put 200
million dollars in the box collectively
and they start getting these x tokens
for it right and now all of a sudden
everyone's like wow people just decide
to put 200 million dollars in the box
this is a pretty cool box right like
this this is a valuable box as
demonstrated by all the money that
people have apparently decided should be
in the box
and for we to say that they're wrong
about that like
you know this is i i mean boxes can be
great look i love boxes as much as the
next guy
right
and so
what happens now all of a sudden people
are kind of recalibrating it's like well
20 million dollars that's it like that
market cap for this box and it's been
like 48 hours and it already has 200
million dollars and fleeing from like
sophisticated players in it are you guys
hearing this he literally just described
a ponzi scheme unironically and said at
the top of this interview by the way
that this is one of the most important
things in d5 right now boxes that do
nothing that are in the shape of
pyramids and by the way you and i aren't
the only ones who feel stunned by this
the interviewers are just sort of at a
loss for words i i think of myself as
like a fairly cynical person and yep
that was so much more cynical yeah this
should i guess i would have described
farming like you're just like well i'm
in the ponzi business and it's pretty
good
did any of this require any sort of like
economic case it's just like other
people make money in the box and so i'm
going to too and then it's more valuable
so i'm going to put more money in and at
no point in the cycle did it seem to
like describe any sort of like economic
purpose now it was at this point in the
interview where i thought okay
finally some sensible people in the room
clearly sam just got called out for
pitching ponzi schemes he's now going to
backtrack right wrong instead sam goes
um this is my world and uh you guys are
boomers and just don't understand how
money works and it is sort of like real
monetizable
stuff in some senses and
you know at some point like if the world
never decides that we were wrong
about this in like a coordinated way
right like you're kind of the guy
calling [ __ ] saying no this thing's
actually worthless but in what sense are
you right
you could see something get mark
happened the way that i don't know
dogecoin or shibcoin have right where
people just kind of like haha and then
they buy it
and if you're like that's dumb it has no
cash flow i'm gonna short sell it you
lose all your money there it is guys the
unironic investment case for memes and
ponzi schemes they have value because
people say they have value and who are
you to say otherwise i mean what do you
even say to this because on the one hand
this is insane and breaks all monetary
theory on the other hand that guy has a
billion dollars well multiple billions
and i have
multiple thousands we are not the same
okay that's all i'm saying so what do we
even take away from this i think the
answer has to be nothing i hope you guys
learned nothing there is no good lesson
here
but only maybe a few chuckles and laughs
at the inevitable decline of our society
into pure ponzinomics if you want to
watch the rest of this debate
relitigating whether ponzi schemes are
actually a great idea uh i'm gonna link
the full thing down below in the
description thanks for watching that's
it pump the stock it's probably a ponzi
scheme but hey sam said it was okay
see ya